quelques minutes d'échauffement avant
l'épreuve finale depuis huit jours les
centaines de lycéens se sont succédé ici
sous le regard d'un jury exigeant pour
eux le bébé est souvent une histoire de
famille et beaucoup pratiquer toute
l'année en association oui parce que
pour moi c'est ma culture et maman
vendre leurs amis aussi et parce que
j'aime beaucoup c'est aussi très à
l'aise oui j jacques élevé à petit et
puisque j'ai commencé depuis petit après
je me suis dit si c'est vrai mais j'ai
mis les bouchées doubles d'option avec
les musiciens de la coordination baylet
sont là pour accompagner les danseurs
des élèves sont notés sur plusieurs
prestations au groupe et en individuel
grand bailey ou kalenda chacun sera jugé
sur sa technique et son expressivité son
endurance sa relation à l'autre
un univers très codifié que les gardiens
de la tradition ne prennent pas du tout
à la légère
sa commande et un certain nombre
d'investissements qu'elle n'est pas qu'à
trouver toutes les portes et nous et
allogènes inscrit qu une option parce
que tu es tu aussi bayless a fasciné et
allogènes partir de pièces association
qui veut dit au pape prie paris option
avec jeudi à gaza il n'ya belle quand
même puisque seuls moyeu à
l'échauffement seulement une toute la
muse a fait l'apprentissage de josiane
avec un doublé de la beaucoup de titres
cadeaux et en fait il ya beaucoup de de
règle est respectée au niveau des
positions de du son il faut être à
l'écouté du tambour et ouais non si
c'est parce que en hausse comme ça et à
qui un jour voilà non pas du tout c'est
vraiment une baisse que depuis la
seconde la pratique au lycée et de deux
heures par semaine mais les profs de ps
ponctuent l'année de stages et
rencontres culture nous mêmes au niveau
par exemple de notre mission d'une
semaine culturelle dans laquelle
systématiquement depuis une quinzaine
d'années l'atelier baylet travail donc
ça permet à ces jeunes de se confronter
au public avec une proximité puisque
généralement c'est dans l'allée centrale
les choses comme ça ou alors des
rencontres comme aux marins où il ya par
exemple d'ici le 4 mai l'atelier baylet
fait un spectacle par exemple
l'épreuve qui comprend également un oral
permet de glaner quelques points pour le
bac
certains candidats vont décrocher 20 sur
20 mais avec la réforme du bac toutes
ces options vont disparaître karl
coûterait trop cher à l'état
l'option baylet disparaîtra après 2020